سفيان القصف اذا الروسي على يعيد تسليط
الضوء على اهميه المقاطعه الواقعه غربيه
اوكرانيا اذ تعد بوابه عبور معظم شاحنات
او شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه المقدمه الى كيف
منذ بدء الحرب حيث تصل تلك الاسلحه
ثم يتم شحنها برا الى داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كما كانت المقاطعه التي تعد
مركزا تجاريا واقتصاديا مهما في اوكرانيا
احدى الاماكن التي شهدت نزوح الاوكرانيين
والراغبين في اللجوء الى دول او في دول
اوروبا نحوها مع بدايه الحرب كانت لذيذ
تستقبل قرابه 60 الف نازح يوميا وشهدت
مدينه ليفيف النقل الكثير من الدول
السفاراتها وممثلياتها اليها في الاشهر
الاولى من الحرب مثل الولايات المتحده
والمجر ودول اخرى قبل ان تعيد تلك الدول
سفاراتها الى كييف في وقت لاحق المقاطعه
شهدت ضربات روسيه متكرره رغم تباعد
فتراتها الزمنيه بدايه هذا الشهر اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدمير قواتها مخزن
اسلحه تسلمتها كياف من بولندا